good morning John it's Monday December
29th and sometimes I forget how amazing
it is to have a fan base that is
entirely and completely and purely
native awesome and then I can feature it
on the front page when they start
getting comments like this one WTF are
you some kind of gay nerd Homo sapiens
activist sure I'll be a gay nerd Homo
sapiens activists if if you want to call
that about thing then I'll be one my
wife might get a little bit angry about
the gay part but everything else I'm
sure she will be a hundred percent in
favor of back when John and I first
started on YouTube probably 50% of our
comments were negative and now because
we have the nerdfighters who for those
of you who don't know what a nerdfighter
is mostly they are people who like to
watch John and I and other nerdfighter
programming on YouTube they are also
people who instead of being made bones
and organs and stuff on the inside are
actually made of Awesome and
nerdfighters believe in fighting for the
rights of nerds and for intellectualism
and for accepting people for who they
are
so the nerdfighters generally have very
kind and supportive things to say to us
but then you get on the front page and
there are a lot of non nerdfighters
watching the programming and suddenly
you remember how hateful YouTube can be
the only difference now is that when the
haters come out the nerdfighters pounce
generally I think that nerdfighters do a
really good job of insulting people
though and frequently they do it by
invoking Shakespeare zoster Tosta
responded to a pretty offensive comment
thusly thou fell lurking cur resembling
a wagtail embossed carbuncle in fact I'm
a really big fan of responding to haters
comments with Shakespearean insults I
think that that is proof that there is a
great well of awesome in the world and
that it's only just being uncapped it
seems that many of the hitters in fact
are just the same person commenting over
and over again which makes me feel a
little bit better about the nature of
YouTube and even these just not tens of
thousands of evil people it's just you
know 10 evil people commenting thousands
of times each for example Zac Efron for
life is a real meanie you wouldn't
expect that guy from for life to be a
real maybe but he's real meanie and I
kind of want to get in touch with Zac
Efron for life just so that I can
contact him in 30 years and see if it
really was that guy from for a life it
just occurred to me that Zac Efron for
life is probably a girl I don't really
think about girls as haters very often
but you know maybe Zac Efron Profis is a
girl hater I heard that you had a pretty
good
and that you received among other things
a personal trainer good luck getting off
the pounds there buddy I in fact weigh
about 15 pounds more than I used to so
maybe I'll be going down the road
eventually as well I as you probably
know received rock band and that has
been fun my wrists hurt it's really hard
bar the thing is took a bit of it it's
it's fun now and I got Katherine a
ukulele you kill Allah hopefully you
will see a hanging Katherine duet in the
future guitar ukulele style and of
course I want to thank you very much for
all of my llama butts I mean honestly
I'm having a hard time I'm at in my life
before I had those llama butts how did I
live a couple of housekeeping things
there are a lot of people who are
wondering where their copy of so jokes
is I can promise you that it is not on
my desk unfortunately it turns out that
it is much more difficult to ship out
large quantities of things at the same
time than we had originally assumed you
need a special device and license in
order to do that and so we are in the
process of acquiring that device and as
soon as we do they will go out but I
don't have an estimated date for you
right now I'm very sorry about that so
you don't have to worry about that we
didn't get your order and we're about to
send out several hundred copies of so
jokes if you haven't reordered them you
can go do that now at dftba.com second
little announcement for everybody I'm
looking for people who are interested in
one environmental technology and people
who are too interested in active in
social news like Digg and reddit and
stumble upon in that kind of thing
because a friend of my I are working on
a project and we are wondering if you
would like to be included so we need
people who are interested environment
technology and we need people who are
currently involved in social news send
me a letter to sparks fly 4G be calm
with environmental technology in the
subject line and if you spell it wrong I
won't get the email so spell it right
Java should be off for now I will see
you very soon in a video which we will
discuss the future of nerd fighting on
YouTube for 2009 and it would be a very
exciting discussion indeed we have some
amazing plans for 2009 so Rach don't
forget to be awesome